we'll stick to their main openings
so i wouldn't expect any sidelines
to to i wouldn't expect to see any
sidelines in the world championship
match i think ian would stick to his
usual openings
which is the grunfeld and the sicilian
and i think magnus will stick to the
main lines when he's white
uh
so yeah i think players would stick to
ian and magnus will stick to the opening
that they know the most
so i don't think they would play any
sidelines
for example i don't think ian would play
the french winner again
uh he played the winner twice in the
candidates but he didn't really get
good positions from that opening
so i don't expect to see the winner
again
but i expect to see maybe the petros
and the sicilian nidorfs so either one
of those openings
bishop e3
i i can actually play e5 and try to trap
this knight on h5
so he should have played night maybe he
should have taken an h5 with
the g pawn that's not the knight strap
i should sleep wesley can you play me
okay if you i
i sure can i'll put you up next
i i pick burger them
that's a nice name
so actually ian only played the petros
maybe a couple of times in his career
only a handful of games but still he
he played the better very convincingly
against wang hao
so we might see that opening once again
it seems to soil style actually
f4 bishop c1
yes this earlier yeah thank you bogdan
for the game
anyone know who's taking bets on this
championship game
i think there is a site where where they
take bits
magnus will cloud him to start to match
that's a good one
magnus
i don't think we'll ever see the bone
cloud in
any match though
bishop takes so
uh i guess white is a couple pawns up
should be easily winning
oh why did i just hang upon
i guess i drop upon for no reason
but if i get f4 f5 in
so i pick your fourth grade student from
where
why did i play king
hmm
rookie five through e8
that's a good one beware wesley makes
sure he plays his best chess against
fourth graders
height interesting
shout out to you in the philippines
so what time is it there in the
philippines
[Music]
okay